Are we going to do any unpacking or analysis on the fact that
people's immediate response to you is to call you a pedophile?
Right here, right now, you're announcing to the world that you
got a hair transplant? Yeah, I did. Yeah. Yeah. Uh 3,500 grafts.
I got I got like most of it. So so there there there's a a slight
bald spot still still in the back here, but
>> Uh can I ask you So like last time you were going to
come
Yeah. you I think you started streaming. How's streaming going?
How are like some of the plans you've been doing? I know you
made a subreddit last I saw. Yeah. Oh yeah. Um
I mean yeah, I've been doing a ton of fun stuff. Um I'm okay.
Honestly, the my 15 minutes of fame is over >> is is what
I'll say. Like nobody nobody's reaching out to me anymore. But
I think that's that's kind of a good thing. Um
I'm just like messing around. Uh
here's an example of project I'm making. I'm calling it Harry
without Harry. So I'm using AI and I'm removing Harry Potter
from the movie Harry Potter. And Yeah. That's it's going to be
a funny joke, but that that's it. And so I'm I'm doing stuff
like that. I also have a product called clips.gg. >> Can
I ask you Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
You know who Purple Perry Gaming is? Okay. He's a crazy person.
Okay, he was Have you been watching a lot of his videos? That
was like a Perry cadence and everything. That was like a Perry
cadence right there. I heard it. Did anyone else hear
I I I I I I've been working on this this this a concept called
the Harry without Harry. Harry without Harry. And uh it's like
a joke. It's like a bit. It's like a bit. You get it? You get
it? Cuz that's you right now. I Okay. That was I've not seen
any of his videos. Okay. I just remember him like
I Okay. I I do have a grudge against him because he was like
um coming into my Discord or something demanding that he debate
me when I was getting all these messages. This is very annoying.
So I do have a grudge against him.
I just I legitimately you just said something that like I actually
thought was just Perry. I thought you were literally just doing
like a Perry meme there. Like a Perry
impression. I'm not even joking. That's what it sounded like
to me. Okay. All right. I'll maybe I'll have to look at his stuff.
Um but yeah, I I mean honestly, I can see answer your question.
I'm doing like five 10 different projects.
I I mean I know nobody in my community who actually thought the
clip.gg thing was good.
Yeah. Yeah, somebody reached out to me.
and I I have blew him off because
Who's the substance He's Okay, the substance guy is like crazy,
dude. He was like, "You should talk to the substance guy." No.
Um I'll do it for your stuff, but >> Substance isn't crazy.
What do you mean? Substance isn't crazy at all. He's He's targeted
me. I I forget why.
>> What do you mean targeted? Did he clip
Something like that. I just I I don't
I don't remember my grudges. Okay? I just I know that they're
correct. And I don't I don't care how it started.
And so that's it. You like you you nuke me one time. You you
be bad faith one time. That's it. Did he nuke you?
I I think so. I don't remember what it but I was mad at him.
for a while.
>> All right.
So pick a different If you got other
I'll I'll help them out, but not him.
Oh, I wasn't even No, no, no, no, I I there's somebody else in
my community who was like interested to do AI stuff all the time.
Are you ready to like bury the hatchet with Queenman? Can we
like Can we end the beef? Can we end that beef? >> He's
so He's like the
Okay, he's not as bad as Purple He's not as bad as Purple Perry.
>> He's really not that threatening. Okay? He He's like
second to Purple Perry. He's not as bad as him. Okay, he's he
like there are worse people than
Um but he he's he's quite annoying. What do you mean annoying?
Is the voice cracks? I don't I don't just respect people who
just like go off and like like bad faith you all the time. And
it's like it's like really annoying. What What did he say that
was bad faith?
What was it? I was It was on Twitter. There was It was It's always
on Twitter. Maybe I just need to stop going on That would solve
a lot of my problems. I made a points against him and then he
ignored it and then he just did like an insult on me. And I forget
And that's that's just my life. It is >> I guarantee [clears throat]
if I go look at it is he was arguing with you. He asked you a
question. You evaded answering. You basically wrote a response
that didn't answer the question like intentionally. And then
he gets very mad and he starts insulting people. If you do if
you do like an evasion like a non-answer to a question he asks,
he will start insulting you viciously.
Okay, here here's I'll make
I'll make a half Here's Here's a deal I'll make. Okay, he's got
to say one thing in good faith that I'm like right about. And
if he can do that, I'll bury the hatchet.
Like Reddit Okay, I think Reddit is important. How How do How
does nobody else agree with me? Okay, everybody made fun of me
for saying that like Reddit is important. I think it's important.
>> Hold on. Hold on. I'm being linked to I'm being linked
to
See here.
This [clears throat]
guy is totally worthless and I've never seen a fan of his who
seemed capable of living without a care. Glad Ethan has inspired
him to start Not you, by the way. This is Tectone. Sure. Counterpoints.
What if people just didn't go around randomly making accusations
of people being pedos? Is that really so hard? Have your civil
rights ever civil rights been infringed upon because you can't
shout pedo at people you don't like. Nobody called him a pedophile.
Very So yeah.
Yeah, nobody called him a pedophile here
Yeah, no nobody called him a pedophile
You're I've called him What What What is Tectone arguing about?
Cuz I think Tectone is saying he's going to sue people for calling
people pedos.
Oh, maybe. Queenman didn't
I guess it's it's like one level indirect, I guess.
In any case, nobody called him a pedophile. Very embarrassing
that you jumped to the defense of every over 5K every streamer
over 5K current.
Hold on. Hold on. You hope this guy will give you more than time
of day at TwitchCon. Sad bald bastard, get back to
His direct accusation is that he is suing because someone is
calling him a pedo. It's in the clip. That person didn't call
him a pedophile. He's lying.
Okay, but don't you think it's better to actually address the
substance here?
You do like substance. It's probably not
It's probably bad if you just take Tectone's word for it, but
we'll keep
Okay, don't you think you should address the substance instead
of jumping off the
and just saying that it's about suing critics, which doesn't
even bring up the
Hold on. See, you're going in a bad direction here. You immediately,
right? If somebody is lying about what someone's saying and and
then threatening to sue them, that is them trying to silence
critics like right Sorry. >> could say why they're wrong
though. You couldn't just say
like you shouldn't just say the the opposing argument. Well,
like cuz I thought that was a pretty That's like the substance
of the clip is is the accusation a pedo accusation.
And then But he's saying he's being called a pedophile. He's
not showing the accusation, right? He's just He's just characterizing
it. Why don't you put the weight on him when he makes a claim?
Prove it.
Sure. Uh
Okay, but now now that's like a is annoyed that it because he's
like a big streamer, you are without him doing anything to prove
out the claim he's making, you are believing him and then telling
everybody else to disprove him.
I guess you kind of got to say that like if he had if Queenman
had responded to me and said like, "Actually no, he didn't show
any proof that the person was a pedo." But like the person didn't
need to mention the pedo accusations at all. But and then that
would have been a good argument. He's saying nobody called him
a pedophile.
You're You're taking You're taking Tectone's side and assuming
somebody called him a pedophile, right? No, I I I want to and
then he
argue against that, right? I I I wanted somebody to say >> Why?
Why Why wouldn't you go watch the Tectone thing and see if he
actually
if if somebody actually called him a
Why wouldn't you say, "Hey, Tectone,
Did Did somebody call you a pedophile?
Where'd that happen?" Because I want to see the answer I mean,
I just saw the clip. Okay, so so maybe
Now we're like five levels deep of like, "Okay, did I verify
his claim?"
>> Tectone said somebody called him a pedophile and he's
going to sue. You should go, "Hey, I've never seen any evidence
of that. Who called you a
Y- That's how your thought process should work. It shouldn't
be, "Well, actually, these guys are all trying to persecute this
big streamer cuz he's just so good at it and and and and and
now I need you guys to prove that you didn't call him a pedophile.
What the Explain this whole thing to me. Okay, but that's the
point of the response. Like the point of a response of like you're
saying this person is wrong is for you to give that context.
There is no context except for nobody called him a pedophile.
You should have said that first. Which is presented without evidence.
It's without evidence, right? What I'm saying is I'll get I would
say that he's right if he said that before my statement. So if
that was the first thing that he said was he didn't call him
a pedophile. But it didn't seem like he was addressing that point.
But I sure. But like
I don't understand. You're like you're taking what Tectone said
at face value. Like Queenman saying he's just suing critics.
Instead of taking Queenman at face value, you're taking Tectone
at face value. No, I I I want somebody if you're responding to
somebody, address the argument. So like if say why the person
is wrong. So it's it's you got to actually address that in some
way.
I see why or I I get why you feel like that needs to happen.
I think Queen is just here.
Yeah, I don't I don't like that. I don't I don't I I I want people
to talk about the that's what I don't like.
But fine. I I mean I'm still offering >> should stop going
on Twitter then if you just don't like people's
I I did I've had
Twitter is actually one of the worst platforms ever. I had the
same thing with that with Chud Logic, dude. Okay, I like tried
to engage with him on Sub Sense and then he was just like you
look like a pedo and it's like all right, dude. You too. And
then and then I made a video about him. You You understand that's
because you talk it like I can be calm with people who are can
never ever ever ever ever admit they're wrong on something, but
most people aren't like that. Most people eventually like the
third time you loop on the same thing without acknowledging where
something is
where like why you're wrong or what the other person like you
you can't see that you're looping repeatedly. After the third
time people yeah, just go like you're a pedophile. You're an
F-slur.
peel out of the conversation.
It's it was it's not never on the third time. Okay, if you're
right if it was like three or four responses down but it's never
that. It's always like the first one. Okay, I would be a lot
happier with Twitter if somebody just like gave one or two responses
and then like and then call me that. >> are we going to
do any unpacking or analysis on the fact that people's immediate
response to you is to call you a pedophile?
Have we done any thinking on this? I mean it's an easy dunk,
I guess and then also it's just it's Twitter so that's the answer.
Okay. I don't get called a pedophile that often. Queen, do you
get called a pedophile very often?
I mean I'm sure it's like an appearance thing, right? I mean
like I'm not going to pretend like that's not an easy easy thing
to attack me on, right? Like like oh, you're you're bald or whatever.
You're slightly overweight but like whatever. I don't I don't
care about
>> Well, hold on. Queen says yes, he gets called a pedophile
a lot but that's not the point. That is funny. I'll I'll give
I'll give him the funny funny funny joke for that. Have you have
you thought about K like you are rich?
Why don't you have a flight booked to Turkey right now? All right.
I did I didn't Okay.
I didn't want to say this cuz it feels like the internet won.
No, they didn't win. Just be happy. Stop thinking about whether
the internet won. Go to Turkey. Get your hair transplant. >> no,
I got I got I got I actually I went to Texas actually. So that
that I got one three days ago actually.
There's no way. Really? Right here right now you're announcing
to the world that you got a hair Yeah, I did. Yeah. Yeah. 3500
grafts, right? Pretty Texas was pretty cheap at least compared
to San Francisco. >> Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. It does
it look good yet or is it like going to take some time to heal
and sh
I I mean it's it's clear that I'm half sh I mean I'll I'll do
a reveal if you want, I guess. So you you can do the >> Hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I need to I need to Hold on. Hold
on. This is huge. It's massive. Hold on. I need you don't turn
your camera on yet. I need it to be on stream before before I
actually Sure.
Let me just
I'll I'll tell you when you can go. If you're if you're ready,
just let me know. Let's turn the light on. Okay.
Uh I guess I'll start the video call. NO!
STILL! STILL! COME BACK, STILL!
STILL! There's no way. There's no way. There's no way. Did he
Did he just stroll me?
I mean kind of won. I was I was excited.
Bro, what does 3500 grafts mean? That is actually kind of funny.
I was so excited for him though. He better actually have gotten
a hair
I I don't I don't even care that he lied to me about revealing
right now on I don't care at all.
All I care about is that he's actually getting the hair transplant.
As long as he's actually getting the hair transplant, we're all
good. I wanted to believe.
Just like the aliens thing all over
Wait. Hold on. Wait.
Yep. Oh my god. Hold on. He wasn't lying. HE WASN'T LYING. YEAH.
Hold on. Hold on. Wait, it's not ready on stream because it's
a different window. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
No, not that.
This. OH MY GOD.
HE WASN'T LYING. YEAH, SO IT'S IT'S it's
I got I got like most of it. So so there there there's a a slight
bald spot still still in the back here but um that's that's all
the That's all they could do at the time. >> crazy. That's
all they could do at the
>> Wait, are you going to get like more done at some point?
Um I mean I'll have to see how it looks, I guess. Um I mean they
said that I should probably like wait a year for things to to
heal but I mean I think it's
I I mean they said they I mean I I trust the the experts so they
said it it looked good so yeah.
That's awesome. I can't wait until it grows out. Very excited.
You'll have to come back for like a 6-week progress
Yeah, we'll do. Yeah.
Yeah, that's awesome.
All right.
Are you ready I dude, are you getting ready to hit the gym now?
You know is this the year of the Still
Uh you're nowhere near So I don't know
to tell you this cuz it's going to sound like I'm being a like
you would be heavier if I just see like your face. I watched
you play DDR and I was like holy this guy is like actually like
your face carries more weight than the rest of your body. I don't
know if you know that.
Yeah, I'm really good at it. I mean I will say I'm very good
at DDR. Okay, I've I've been doing that for a while. But yeah,
I guess I think my face is a little bit little little pudgy.
Could lose
probably 25 lbs. >> it's not even No, it's not a criticism
or anything. I'm just saying that like I thought you'd be like
a bigger guy. You weren't so you don't even have that much to
do. Okay? You could have like a ton of work. You don't have that
much work. Yep. Yeah. It's it's doable. 2026 the year of the
Still ascendancy. Exactly.
The comeback.
Yeah, let's go.
All right. Um do you have anything else you want to talk about
or just uh docs and stuff and I think yeah, that's it for now.
Um
Who knows what other
crazy projects I'll have or or virality. I don't know. I think
I think my 15 minutes of fame is done now. I think uh Yeah, so
you're not you're not going to see me for for a little while
unless I have another crash out. But yeah, it's good chatting.
Okay. Yeah, it's cool chatting. All right. I'm psyched about
the hair transplant. I also we all thought you pranked me by
the way. We all thought you disconnected.
Uh everybody was like oh my god, he faked getting a hair transplant
and then he got us all excited and then he pieced
But you left and then called me instead of revealing it there.
Okay. Did it? Yeah. Okay, I didn't know that. Yeah. Yeah, we
all thought you we thought you Everybody was like Still won.
Still fooled you. Fooled you. Like he totally
You actually lied to us. >> real. Yeah.
All right.
Good chatting. >> Thanks for chatting. I'll see you see
you later. Bye. Bye.
What a crazy day. What a what a totally crazy day.
Okay, so still angry at Still. Okay.
I don't know. I I just like when people make themselves better.
I like when uh I like when they get over something like wanting
to not get a hair transplant cuz the internet is going to win.
I like when they get over like that and then they can just be
better people.
You know what I'm saying? Hard to hard to be angry about it.